sin rastro de la vacuna contra el cob y
19 en haití un año después del inicio de
la pandemia la nación de más de 11
millones de habitantes no ha recibido ni
una sola inyección a 756 mil dosis de
astrazéneca asignadas a través del
mecanismo de naciones unidas- kóvacs y
cuya entrega está prevista para antes de
mayo podrían retrasarse puesto que las
autoridades no realizaron correctamente
los procedimientos con apirm un goya la
cab bendito que le vacían de conozco
mucha gente que pregunta cuándo estarán
disponibles las vacunas porque necesitan
vacunarse lo que significa que hay gente
que quiere vacunarse y hay gente que
está obligada a vacunarse por su medio
de vida o su profesión visión el que ya
en la empobrecida nación caribeña sumida
en varias crisis de seguridad política y
social que desde inicio de año ha
llevado a miles a salir a protestar a
las calles carece de la infraestructura
necesaria para garantizar el
almacenamiento adecuado del suero según
las autoridades
si bien las mascarillas son obligatorias
en las plazas de mercado apenas son
visibles
se supone que el gobierno nos va a dar
más mascarillas para el coronavirus pero
no nos dan las mascarillas y no sabemos
dónde ir a comprarlas las venden a un
precio más alto del que podemos pagar
somos pobres no podemos pagarlas por eso
no usamos mascarillas fácil para no es
que muchos haitianos no creen en el
coronavirus un desafío que podría poner
en jaque su frágil sistema de salud y la
percepción de la población que no cree
en la existencia del cobi 19 la
reticencia de una gran parte de la
población a ir a hacerse las pruebas
incluso cuando tienen algunos síntomas
que parecen de gripe mucha de la gente
podría pensar que el kobe no existe
esa es una de las grandes luchas la gran
negación de la existencia de la
enfermedad
en esta habilidad hace que muchos se
pregunten cómo se van a administrar las
vacunas en una nación donde la población
se preocupa más por la violencia la
pobreza que por el virus